personalmente implicado así definir un
tribunal de versalles la participación
de karim benzema en el intento de
extorsión al jugador francés mathieu
valbuena y por lo que fue sentenciado un
año de prisión suspendida además del
pago de una multa de 75 mil euros
matthew se siente aliviado al ver el
final de este procedimiento porque los
últimos años han sido muy duros ha
sufrido daños que son difíciles de
reparar siempre ha enfrentado este
calvario con coraje discreción y
honestidad por eso hoy estamos
satisfechos de que sea reconocida su
condición de víctima wittstock entró en
octubre de 2015 valbuena denunció que
estaba siendo extorsionado a cambio de
no difundir un vídeo con contenido
sexual que él implicaba y que
presuntamente habría sido robado de su
teléfono móvil benzema que no estuvo
presente en el juicio realizado en
octubre pasado por compromisos
profesionales fue relacionado por una
conversación que mantuvo con valbuena el
6 de octubre de 2015 y en la que
advertía sobre las consecuencias de no
atender la extorsión sus abogados
expresaron que apelarán el fallo
sin el mundo las reacciones de enfado
por esta sentencia que es perfectamente
contradictoria de hecho el propio
tribunal declaró claramente que karim
benzema no estaba al tanto de las
maniobras previas y luego al final se
nos dice que no lo pudo haber sabido sin
pruebas y esto lo que condenamos
condenamos esta sentencia muy severa que
es injusta sin pruebas realmente estamos
bastante pasmados por este juicio la
peli de nuevos son obviamente es
necesaria una apelación y debemos apelar
porque karim benzema no tiene nada de
culpa en este caso si será absuelto en
el tribunal de apelación show de lectura
pero
el caso afectó parte de la carrera
deportiva de benzema quien fue apartado
de la selección de su país por casi seis
años hasta la eurocopa de 2020 cuando
fue llamado sorpresivamente desde
entonces ha sido figura del equipo con 9
goles en 13 partidos